packing arts is a festival and hackathon
exploring the intersection of art
entertainment technology and
entrepreneurship I come from a company
called vzyal son but also from a work of
art that's called little Sun and a
global project that we would call little
Sun it's based on the simple but
astonishing fact that 1.6 billion people
in the world don't have access to
electricity the sun goes in the top here
and then you have a little lamp that
shines in the night you can take
traveling you can take it walking take
it everywhere some people adopt it as
our eggs and we'll take this design some
will just take it as a lamp and others
will take it as a symbol of positive
access to energy divided emotions beauty
and participation what parts of Africa
have you been already operating you
we're operating in Ethiopia Kenya Uganda
Zimbabwe Senegal in South Africa with a
hackathon you get a chance to to work on
something change it see it in a
different way make it simple simplicity
is crucial the idea should be like an
elevator picture
I like that little drop little son
connection there that's really striking
we pass water through a tube that's
exposed to UV light and it basically
cleans out all the bacteria in the water
you can see that water is kind of going
this way so you have the two LEDs and
you have led that kind of powers that
what we're proposing is a community
that's centered around a website that's
going to help the people who are
involved in selling distributing little
sense do everything to explore to
connect to join we ended up having a
pretty even split of entrepreneurs
artists and engineers we started out
with just totally bouncing off ideas and
going super divergent and then whittling
it down and now we're finally getting
into like actually building a prototype
but how amazing have the last two days
when are you guys having fun I'm really
curious to see the community-based idea
because that could be an interesting
part of exactly this the communication
is really a vital thing hi everyone my
name is chris i'm maria and we are part
of little son community this is a
platform which connects vendors to one
another to allow them to explore connect
and also join a community have you made
art with little son have you found a
practical use for little son or have you
found it a cool way of making it your
newest fashion accessory a lot of those
people in those very same communities
need something else they need clean
drinking water this is little drop it's
a solar-powered LED water treatment
device the straw spools through some
germicidal UV LED light bulbs what the
little drop provides like lil son is an
emotional experience so you
differentiate yourself from the ones
that are on the market by it's more an
emotional connection have you ever hurt
the light of the Sun
so basically we're hearing the light
transforming that into an audio device
something you guys just did like over
the last 48 hours it's like extremely
simple directly wiring up up to this for
those headphone jacks thing I find
really impressive about hackathons is
people really kind of come in and
they're just they're so completely open
to making totally new connections and
then spending a lot of time working on
something with someone who they just met
the price goes to the Sun community team
you